éduquer un enfant pour moi c'est pas
seulement lui apprendre à être sage et
arrêts
parker éduquer un enfant c'est lui
permettre de s'épanouir d'apprendre à la
fois en coopération mais également en
autonomie d'apprendre des leçons oui
mais également des valeurs celles de la
société et celle de la vie imaginez
maintenant un système sans notation
imaginé un système où l'enfant peut
choisir de travailler matière en
priorité sans pour autant délaisser les
autres par la suite imaginé un système
où il enfin va pouvoir découvrir des
activités telles que la cuisine le
jardinage le bricolage la couture et
bien d'autres autant d'activités que
deux centres d'intérêts potentiels voilà
un système qui va pouvoir s'adapter à
tous les profils aider ceux qui se
sentent le plus en retrait et
accompagner ceux qui se sentent le mieux
là vous vous dites qu'il s'agit de
belles images pour ce qui est une belle
utopie et moi je vous dis que ça existe
et que j'en viens j'ai vécu cinq ans en
pédagogie alternative mais cinq années
de primaire
ça m'a permis de me construire comme je
suis aujourd'hui de m'épanouir et
peut-être même que c'est grâce à tout ce
que m'a apporté cette pédagogie que j'ai
décidé de parler tout ça devant vous
quand on évoque les pédagogies
alternatives
une des premières questions qui vient
c'est de savoir si les élèves vont
apprendre la même chose quand système
traditionnel et bien oui et peut-être
même plus
eh bien il faut savoir en pédagogie
alternative
les critères d'évaluation et les
compétences à acquérir vont être les
mêmes qu'en système traditionnel mais la
pédagogie alternative telle que moi je
l' ai vécu c'est d'abord un fort esprit
de coopération et une véritable cohésion
de groupe
ça va passer des discussions des
échanges des débats pendant les cours de
français d'histoire de sciences mais
surtout et réunion copé les réunions de
copé ce sont des réunions coopération on
va pouvoir discuter et débattre de la
classe et de son organisation
vous avez bien entendu l'élève a le
droit de proposer des idées d'argumenter
de pointer du doigt des éléments qui
peuvent lui semblait peu claires et
d'essayer d'apporter des choses
bénéfiques à la classe pour bien sûr je
vous arrête tout de suite des idées
telles qu avoir une piscine dans la
classe ou bien des récréations 2h30 ne
seront pas retenus
mais ce type de thé change ça forge
vraiment à la prise de parole spontanée
à la réflexion et bien sûr ses forges à
créer de nouvelles idées moi c'est ce
qui m'a donné envie par la suite d'être
simple délégués de classe au collège au
lycée puis entrer au cv elle aussi avait
elle qui sont des institutions lycéenne
pour participer plus activement à la vie
lycéenne et faire entendre ma voix vont
revenir un petit peu à la coopération
elle existait également au sein de toute
l'école entre les spectacles les
ateliers les lectures de textes qui
étaient organisées entre tous les
niveaux il était donc pas rare de voir
par la suite des des élèves qui vont en
aider d'autres des cm1 qui vont aider
des cp à faire leurs devoirs ou tout
simplement des élèves d'âge différent
qui jouent ensemble dans la cour de
récréation
il ya là une sorte de tutorat qui se
créent et il est naturel je viens
d'évoquer les ateliers ils sont très
importants
probablement ce qui m'a le plus amusé
fait découvrir le plus de choses et ces
ateliers se sont des sessions de deux
fois une heure où on va pouvoir choisir
une activité parmi celles que j'ai déjà
cité tout à l'heure où bien l'atelier
bricolage
l'atelier bricolage c'était mon préféré
il ya donc l'atelier bricolage
observations cuisine vous allez avoir
donc jardinage vous allez avoir couture
et beaucoup d'autres ce sont des sortes
de sensibilisation à des milieux où l'on
va pouvoir découvrir par exemple comment
le courant passe une pile à une ampoule
comment on construit une petite pièce de
théâtre de a à z ou bien tout simplement
observer des échantillons microscope
mais ça m'a aussi mis quelque peu sur la
voie que je veux suivre aujourd'hui mais
j'en reparlerai plus tard je vous ai
également vanté l'autonomie de l'enfant
et sa capacité à organiser son travail
mais ce n'est pas inné il faut un
apprentissage et un suivi de
l'enseignant il ya bien sûr des temps de
travaux on va pouvoir choisir les
évaluations que l'on veut faire en
priorité parmi des fiches de grammaire
des fiches de science des fiches
d'orthographe des classeurs calcul mais
l'enseignant qui va valider tout ça ne
laissera pas un élève délaissé les
mathématiques au profit la grammaire et
puis il ya les nox dénote tout
simplement je n'en avais pas
pour moi c'était acquis non acquis à
revoir
et vous vous doutez bien qu'en cas de
grosses difficultés
l'enseignant est là pour vous aider bien
sûr mais également vos camarades qui eux
ont peut-être des facilités là où se
trouvent vos difficultés
il ya également un cahier qui assure un
suivi au delà du face à face qui assure
un suivi entre l'enseignant et l'élève
qui est remplie d'observation et de
conseils personnels et pour moi ça c'est
une réelle preuve de suivi
alors moi ce que je préférais c'était
les écritures de texte c'était donc d
expression écrite sur un thème libre qui
était corrigée avec et par l'enseignant
qui vous donner tous les conseils
nécessaires sur la grammaire et
d'orthographe
et encore une fois moi ce n'est pas que
ce n'était pas un très bon élève mais
c'est que j'avais eu beaucoup de mal
avec le système traditionnel car j'avais
beaucoup de difficulté à me concentrer
et organiser mon travail et la pédagogie
alternative
elle m'a beaucoup aidé là dessus elle
m'a donné de la confiance en moi elle
m'a apporté beaucoup de choses et
notamment pour la suite la suite
justement ça a été une véritable
fracture un choc de découvrir le système
traditionnel
non c'est pas vrai ça n'a pas été si
difficile que ça même si tout était
fondamentalement différent
tout d'abord les notes bien évidemment
j'ai trouvé ça quelque peu injuste
d'avoir une mauvaise note voire une très
mauvaise note et qu'on ne revienne pas
forcément dessus c'est raté et ça le
restera
ensuite pour ce qui est de l'intégration
ça n'a pas été difficile ça ça ne l'est
ça n'est pas vraiment pour moi je
m'intègre assez facilement dans les
groupes peu importe les personnes qui
les composent mais la coopération par
contre ça m'a manqué les travaux sont de
plus en plus individuelle et on n'a plus
vraiment la possibilité pendant les
classes de s'entraider aussi un autre
exemple lorsque vous avez des
difficultés un problème dans la classe
avec un autre élève ou peu importe ça ne
va pas forcément ça ne va pas forcément
se régler dans la classe même mais vous
allez allez voir les surveillants les
cpe le principal je trouve ça un petit
peu dommage
bon après bien évidemment il ya des
professeurs qui travaillent selon des
méthodes particulières et qui seront
peut être plus à l'écouté mais l'idée
même des pédagogies alternatives diffère
du système traditionnel
j'ai maintenant vous dire une phrase
qui je pense résume assez bien mon
expérience personnelle j'ai appris à
rêver j'ai appris à essayer cette
pédagogie que j'ai connu je pense
qu'elle est intervenue à des âges qui
sont importants dans l'éveil dans la
constitution d avoir des intérêts et
elle m'a véritablement ouvert l'esprit
sur beaucoup de choses
comme je vous ai dit elle m'a aidé à me
sentir mieux et quand je parle d'
essayer je veux dire que je ne me suis
jamais véritablement imposé de barrières
quand j'étais plus jeune et mes parents
non plus pour tenter d activité d
expérience qui m'attirait c'est comme ça
que j'ai pu pratiquer différents sports
où j'étais plus ou moins bon que j'ai pu
faire du dessin de l'écriture de la
peinture j'ai pu même faire de la
musique ou là pour le coup j'ai été
moins bon mais mais même si ça ne me
plaisait finalement pas j'avais essayé
et je m'étais lancé
là tout de suite si je regarde vers
demain je sais ce que je veux faire je
veux être acteur dans le cinéma c'est un
choix qui a souvent été critiqué
qualifié de futile et je pense que c'est
un choix que j'aurais moi-même
abandonner si j'avais pas eu la
curiosité de m'y intéresser profondément
s'il n'avait pas été accompagné par mon
entourage mais surtout si je n'avais pas
été sensibilisés à des milieux comme
celui ci en étant plus jeune ce qui
s'est passé c'est qu'il ya maintenant un
petit peu plus d'un an j'avais pas trop
quoi faire de ma peau j'adorais le
cinéma
être comédien c'est quelque chose qui
existait dans ma tête mais ça avait
toujours été de l'ordre du rêve
oui c'est ça du rêve et je me suis dit
après une remise en question je me suis
dit pourquoi ne pas faire ce que tu as
toujours fait pour ne pas faire ce qu'on
t'a appris lance toi
et c est à bize
bon je vais essayer de conclure un petit
peu tout ça en disant que pour moi les
pédagogies alternatives elles sont d'une
aide précieuse
elles permettent de s'éveiller
d'apprendre d'ouvrir son esprit ne se
sente de se sensibiliser à des sujets du
quotidien mais aussi et surtout donc
d'être autonome
autonome dans ses choix dans son travail
autonome ou oui mais accompagné
accompagner le temps qu'il faudra pour
ensuite être introduit au système
traditionnel et à la société en général
vous aurez ensuite les clés pour prendre
des décisions allaient au devant des
choses des choses les plus simples aux
choix qui paraissent les plus difficiles
mais je pense aussi et surtout que pour
des élèves qui ont des difficultés comme
ça a été le cas pour moi qui ne se
sentent pas bien ou qui ne sont tout
simplement pas adapté au système
traditionnel les pédagogies alternatives
peuvent être d'un réel secours est une
aide précieuse
non pas pour se réadapter aux systèmes
traditionnels mais pour pallier aux
difficultés et apprendre à user de ces
différences comme d'atouts comme
d'atouts pour l'api merci
[Applaudissements]